hello welcome to science breakthroughs
from science mission I'm sadashiva pi
and going to discuss couple of
breakthrough papers published in the
week of june thirtieth let's start first
we will discuss a paper published by
gopi narendra in the cell on the
identification of pyruvate dehydrogenase
in the nucleus and its function in
acetylation of histones why is this
paper so important nuclear acetylation
is altered in conditions like cancer
neuro degeneration and in cardiovascular
diseases how the nucleus generates
Estill Co a in metazoan cells is not
clear ATP citrate lyase is the
predominant pathway for nuclear spell
coil generation in mammalian cells
authors demonstrate the presence of
pyruvate dehydrogenase in the nucleus
and its role in acetylation of histones
let us look at the data authors
demonstrate the presence of PDC complex
in the nucleus of various cells using
fluorescent probes as shown in this
figure as well as biochemically using
immunoblots they also demonstrate those
dependent increase in labeled Estill Co
a in isolated nuclei and blockage of
Estill Co a formation in the SI RNA for
PDC what is the function of PDC in the
nucleus authors show that PDC acetylate
histones in the nucleus as shown here
using SI RNA they also demonstrate PDC
in mitochondria and is regulated by
pyruvate dehydrogenase kinase but not in
nucleus for the synchronized cells to
the g1 phase by serum starvation for 24
hours and then introduced serum they saw
increased histone acetylation levels
first followed by cycling a they also
found increase in nuclear PDC levels
during cell cycle progression associated
with a parallel decrease in
mitochondrial PDC levels
similar lasers are also seen in
translocation experiments so PDC
translocates from mitochondria to
nucleus what are the factors that affect
translocation others looked into EGF
which is required for s face entry and
found that EGF increased and EGF
inhibitor decreased PDC levels in a549
cells hfp hsp70 that translocates
various proteins found to go in a
precipitate with PDC and the hsp70
inhibitor decreased PDC in the nucleus
similar to SI RNA treatment also auto
show PDC is important for s facing tree
and cell cycle progression so this is an
important discovery that might have
implications in several fields and
disease conditions next let's look into
a paper published by sami and colleagues
in nature chemical biology authors
demonstrate that autophagy enhances
survival of neurons in a less models why
is this paper so important excessive or
mutations in tdp-43 rna-binding protein
has been implicated in els and FTD role
of autophagy in clearing tdp-43 is
controversial authors demonstrate
enhancing autophagy improved survival of
neurons and astrocytes in LS models
automated fluorescence microscopy of
primary rod and neurons transfected with
wild-type and mutated tdp-43 is shown in
this figure risk of cell death as
analyzed by hazard ratio increased
steadily with levels of wild-type and
mutated tdp-43 authors also show by
using optical pulse technology that
mutated protein has lower half life
to understand the role of autophagy or
the screen millions of compounds and
identified three autophagy inducers
these compounds lowered both tdp-43 and
its mutant levels in the neurons as
shown here they also lowered inclusion
bodies and cytoplasmic localization of
mutated tdp-43 what of aging users
decrease that risk in wild-type and
mediated TDP expressing primary neurons
autophagic induction improved survival
of tdp-43 mutant expressed in human IPS
see derived motor neurons astrocytes
differentiated from human ipscs
exhibited mutant tdp-43 related toxicity
that is mitigated by autophagy inducers
so autophagy induction could be used for
treatment of ALS thank you for watching
science breakthroughs from science
mission